残り時間はわずかですが
ご質問などございますでしょうか
もしよかったら挙手されてください
あ どうぞ  今月の初めにですね
アメリカのペンシルベニア州で学校で銃撃事件があって
十人の女の子が死んだというそういう事件があったんですけども
それに対してその遺族のアミッシュの人たちの態度といいますか
行動がですね 犯罪者を許すとか
犯罪者遺族を許すとか
そういうことで 平和で友好的で落ち着いた生活を続けるという
そういうのを見てですね
方法論は全然ブッダとは違うんですけども
己に打ち勝っているというか
そういう面から見ると立派な態度だなというふうに思ったんですね
で まあよく勝者という言葉使いますけども
まあ彼らの勝者なのかなというふうに思ったんですけども
いかがでしょうか  勝者って何？ 勝った方
うんうん まあそんなことで勝者とは言えませんだけど
彼らの態度は正しかったとは思いますけどね
彼らは悲しみをきちっと乗り越えただけのことでしょう
その事件では勝者と言ってもよろしいし
アメリカ人に散々バカにされてますけど
それでもアミッシュたちは自分たちの質素な生活を続けていて
カトリーナハリケーンが出た時でも誰にも助けに行かなかったすっぱなアメリカ人なんですけど
先にアミッシュの人々がいて
一生懸命できることをやっていますし
アミッシュたちは散々非難されているしね
社会に貢献しませんと
みんなと仲良くしませんと
英語は喋りませんとか
なんだらかんだら言いながらね
面白いことにまだ馬車に乗ってるんだからね
牛がかわいそうやと思います
牛じゃ馬がね 車に乗ったって何が悪いか分かりませんだけど
でもそういう人々はどう分かりませんね
穏やかでいるのか どうかわかりませんけど
態度は正しいということでは言えます
だから 何の関係もなく
理不尽的に自分の子供を殺されたんだということで
怒り憎しみを持ってもう裁いてやるぞというふうなことで
自分自身が地獄に行く道を選ばなかったんです
犯罪者は許せませんとかね
言って 犯罪者よりも悪人の悪人になるでしょうね
普通の世界では理不尽的なことで子供を殺されたりしちゃうと
犯罪者地獄に行ってみると
被害者の両親はもっとすごいところにいるんですよ
地獄でも 地獄いたっても悔しいんですよ
俺の子供を殺した奴が軽い苦しみを受けているのに
被害者である私はなんで
もっと厳しい罰を与えて与えられているのかと地獄にいたっても悔しいと思いますよ
だから取るべき態度はアミッシュが取りました
まあ私たちも仏教では取るべき態度はこれやと言うんですけど
バカにされちゃうし まあアミッシュさんはアメリカ人だから
みんなその真似でもするならばありがたいと思います
もう一つ 人間を五蘊という見方をする時あると思うんですけども
その見方というのはアビダンマ的な見方とはまた別なんですか
アビダンマの中に五蘊という言葉が出てくるんでしょうか
色・受・想・行・識  うん
だからどう違うんですかね
アビダンマの中では信と色と信者とそれから涅槃ですか
その四つが真であってという風になってるんですけども
で その時に受想行識がその
まあ信もしくは信者に相当すると思うんですが
識っていう最後の識っていうのはチッタに相当するようなところに来るんでしょうか